parce qu' aucun
et estime toutefois quand john lipsky
qui espère la stratford city q les
terres mais c'est malheureusement j'ai
imaginé ce concept reçoit que malgré sa
pole dancing ou un pied je me moque tout
posé les routes est d'un jaune
voilà pour assister au talent du jeune
des médias le sujet je n'existe que dans
l'ailé quand j'écris se construit grâce
à deux dictionnaires à de lexique du
nouveau jeune un double il ya des poches
qui lance et un ordre de médias de
droite qui est le land vous quelle est
aujourd'hui présent ici posez vous la
question avez vous déjà entendu un jeune
parler de cette manif d expression et
les mots nouveaux
par sa part bien sûr c'est ce qui rend
le final mais langage différent son coin
j'invente et des experts et des
dictionnaires et ce type d lexique du
par les djeuns en approche un peu
partout sur le net à la radio dans les
journaux et même à la télévision
ainsi en a perdu différentes jeunesse
qui existe entre un deuxième cliché qui
nous fait passer pour des idiots
honorable et malgré cela les jeunes
continuent à s'intéresser à la cheville
en 2015 une étude sur les 15 24 ans a
conclu que les gens regardent beaucoup
la télévision pour la riaa le resteront
encore moins maintenant quasiment 90%
sont inscrits sur leur gâteau ce cargo
il 76 % au minimum y stationnera d'eau
par jour
beaucoup plus tôt n'en lisent la presse
autant voire plus que la moyenne
nationale
j'irai niche de large qui traite du
rapport mediagen fois sa globalité et
d'autres études au cul de la même façon
et je le ferai mes informations une
majorité la considère comme important
car oui la jeunesse notre oeil partie de
la jeunesse est engagée politisée a
décidé aimerait participer au débat
public
ce n'est pas parce que nous n'avons pas
le droit des portes que nous n'avons pas
notre mot à dire mais les médias ne le
rates idées pratiques déjà est vraiment
rencontré à joris est ce qui nous
écoutent et nous représente et qui l'a
fait savoir aux niçois jeunesse le
dictionnaire des xi caricatural jeune
junkie d'ailleurs car et attrayante et
d'autres articles jeunesse soit invite à
témoigner sa folle vie avec son
téléphone cette utilisation de la charge
ou quand on donne la parole ce n'est
jamais pour nos idées et lui un côté
comme de l'autre
je suis première satif insulté lorsque
j'ai tout à ça quel journaliste chris
pine et honnête par une jeunesse inculte
et violente qu'il existe deux techniques
et minoritaire tout vous dire quand on
utilisa pas c'est avant tout pour rester
au fait divers
et puis encore faut-il qu'il apparaît
puisque la télévision nous montre à
l'écran lui pour sa de jeunes alors
qu'ils représentent 25% de la population
face à ce constat les jeunes qui la
régissent qui s'organise qui créent les
journaux des radios et maintenant ça ne
prend pas comme ces projets sont pas des
méthodes de jeunes pour jeunes j'ai eu
la chance de fréquenter les journalistes
des devoirs avant contre x au genre
restera toujours la série télé et j'ai
créé leur malaise face à man il n'était
pas habitué à débattre avec un jeune à
parler politique avec un jeu
malheureusement c'est un cerf
j'ai donc pas apparent j'adore on croit
qu'il a rien à dire donc on leur donne
quant à caroline si tu suis les
victoires du temps catastrophique en
2015 une étude a sorti que la france
pour cent 5 19% de 15 de ses 23 passes
codis des landes y ait un contenu varié
a fait ou accentué je ne suis pas cet
avis mais comment pourriez-vous nous
étonner d'où ce résultat grâce à quel
point les médias souvent de la jeunesse
qantas à quel point il représente mal
comment peut-on faire confiance à des
médias jeu nous oublie et j'ai fréquenté
certains des médias créé par les jeunes
j'ai trouvé des mêmes intelligent
passionné par la culture par la radio
dit sans excès il s'exprimer tous
trésorier du lycée du jeune l'unité et
si on est montré et si on les laissait
s'exprimer dans de grands médias et sur
la route et la porte des grands
quotidiens des grands journaux télévisés
je suis première fois que les les jeunes
de débattre avec des adultes
tu lâches restreints à certains journaux
sur l'éducation nationale j'aurais mais
jamais encore jory débattre avec un
professeur ou un homme politique
j'aurai avec musique et se mettre à
leurs interrogations car il fait moins
de se le rappeler le métissage et à tous
les niveaux est une chance
aujourd'hui selon diverses études
une majorité les jeunes est insatisfaite
de la place qu'elle occupe dans la
société n'a pas rien et positive de
l'avenir
et si on vous donnait la parole et sur
la libye s'est s'exprimé il se noue les
faits nous exprimer un point que six
points et vous quand vous oubliez un jeu
mal et vous trouverez la télé koné du
recul est compté comme les jeunes
expriment leur zone
parler des moyens trop et d'autres
textes une réalité
j'espère vous approuver rapidement que
la jeunesse tu as des idées
intéressantes à partager et comme j'aime
bien les jeunes tuent kravtchenko
courage
[Applaudissements]